President Trump will host his first
state dinner tonight with French
president Emmanuel macron as his guest
the president officially welcomed macron
and his wife to Washington at a ceremony
a short time ago last night the McCall's
toured the White House and had dinner
with the Trump's when the two leaders
meet this morning where all will try to
convince mr. Trump to stay in the Iran
nuclear deal Iran's president says the
US will quote face severe consequences
for breaking that agreement major
Garrett is at the White House on day two
of mcrawlins visit major good morning
good morning the two leaders are meeting
right now in the Oval Office after a
welcoming ceremony on the South Lawn
21-gun salute tributes to france's
decisive role in the American Revolution
the president and his remarks emphasized
unity and strength while president
McCrone of France said in any family in
any friendship there are and will remain
some differences
with a peck on both cheeks president
Trump greeted French President Emmanuel
macron at the White House kicking off
the first state visit of his term a tour
of the Oval Office was captured by
macarons photographers outside a sign of
their budding relationship the two
leaders planted this oak sapling gifted
by McCrone to the administration but
that relationship has its hangups over
the three-day trip the two leaders are
expected to tussle over trade and the
Iran nuclear deal the Iran deal was one
of the worst and most one-sided
transactions President Trump wants out
of the deal which temporarily ended
Iran's pursuit of a nuclear weapon in
exchange for relief from economic
sanctions mr. Trump wants to further
clamp down on Iran's ability to develop
nuclear weapons McCrone argues there's
no better alternative and Iran will
resume nuclear activity if the u.s.
backs out that sentiment was confirmed
by Iranian Foreign Minister Javad Zarif
in an interview with face the nation's
Margaret Brennan if the benefits of the
deal for Iran start to diminish then
there is no reason for Iran to remain in
the deal White House press secretary
Sarah Sanders said the president hasn't
shifted his position the president's
been clear from day one that he thinks
that's a bad deal McCrone will also urge
mr. Trump to exempt France and other
European nations from the steel and
aluminum tariffs he announced last month
the state visit and most especially
tonight's state dinner a very big moment
for First Lady Melania Trump the White
House posted a video showing her months
of preparations all the elaborate
details that go into a state dinner that
she herself has supervised one other
thing to note in his opening remarks the
French president talked also about the
need to protect the climate and oceans
also bringing the environmental
differences with the United States and
the Trump administration into the mix of
this very first state visit in the Trump
era major thanks